Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客番外、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我拼不出来。所以你只能用一个假名字，比如你的咖啡馆名字，茱莉亚。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。茱莉亚到底喜欢什么浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改拿铁的订单是不是太晚了？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会想这些了，因为你完全可以在家里自己做浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. All of a sudden, the night turned into day, and it was tremendously bright. The chill turned into warmth. The fireball gradually turned from white to yellow to red as it grew in size and climbed into the sky. After about five seconds the darkness returned but with the sky and the air filled with a purple glow just as though we were surrounded by an aurora borealis. We stood there in awe as the blast wave picked up chunks of dirt from the desert soil and soon passed us by. That was Joe Hirschfeld, who was a chemist who'd been assigned to measure the radioactive fallout from the test on the first atom bomb dropped on the 16th of July, 1945.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。突然之间，黑夜变成了白昼，光芒极其耀眼。寒意化为了暖意。随着火球体积不断增大并爬升向天空，它逐渐从白色变成黄色，又变成红色。大约五秒钟后，黑暗重新降临，但天空和空气中弥漫着紫色的光晕，就像我们被北极光包围了一样。我们惊异地站在原地，此时冲击波卷起了沙漠地面的大量尘土，很快从我们身旁呼啸而过。刚才那是乔·赫什费尔德（Joe Hirschfeld），他是一位化学家，受命测量 1945 年 7 月 16 日投下的第一颗原子弹试验的放射性沉降物。
Dominic, we are thinking about the birth of the atom bomb, the Manhattan Project, all that malarkey. All that malarkey, very good. Well, it's such a somber and kind of overwhelming subject, isn't it? That one wants to perhaps introduce, slightly puncture the gravity of it, because otherwise it's so depressing. And we're doing this obviously because there's a new film out about the life of it, because otherwise it's so depressing. And we're doing this, obviously, because there's a new film out about the life of the man often described as the godfather of the atom bomb, Oppenheimer. And I know so little about Oppenheimer,
多米尼克，我们在思考原子弹的诞生、曼哈顿计划，以及所有这些胡扯。所有这些胡扯，很好。嗯，这是一个如此沉重又有点让人喘不过气的主题，不是吗？人们或许会想稍微冲淡一下它的严肃性，否则实在是太压抑了。我们做这个节目显然是因为有一部关于那位常被称为原子弹之父的男子生平的新电影上映了，否则实在是太压抑了。而我们做这个节目，显然是因为有一部关于常被称为原子弹之父的那位男子生平的新电影上映了，那就是《奥本海默》。而我对奥本海默知之甚少，
I didn't even know what his first name is. I just suddenly realized. His name is J. Robert Oppenheimer, Tom. So what's the J, though? Julius. So his father was called Julius. We'll come on to his parents in a little bit. And by the way, for those people listening, that's the first test. j though julius so his father was called julius we'll come on to his parents a little bit and by the way for those people listening um that that that's the first test that's the trinity test in
我甚至不知道他的名字是什么。我刚刚突然意识到。他的名字叫 J·罗伯特·奥本海默，汤姆。那这个“J”代表什么呢？尤利乌斯（Julius）。所以他父亲叫尤利乌斯。我们一会儿再聊他的父母。顺便说一句，对于听众朋友们来说，那是第一次试验。代表什么呢尤利乌斯所以他父亲叫尤利乌斯我们一会儿再聊他的父母顺便说一句对于听众朋友们来说嗯那那那是第一次试验那是三位一体试验在
new mexico and uh so the bomb wasn't dropped it was sort of installed and then they do the detonation that is that in the hut yes they're exactly they're all miles away that they have in the in the fourth indiana jones film today i think they do. You've been watching a lot of Indiana Jones, Tom, haven't you? Because you're gearing up for a mighty series. Yeah, that's coming next week. So we mustn't get distracted by that. I vaguely remember. Anyway, listen, we don't
新墨西哥州，呃，所以炸弹没有被投掷，而是某种程度上被安装好了，然后他们进行了引爆，那是在棚子里吗？是的，完全是，他们都在几英里外，我想他们在第四部《夺宝奇兵》电影里就是这么干的。汤姆，你最近看了很多《夺宝奇兵》吧？因为你正在为一项重磅系列节目做准备。对，那是下周要播出的。所以我们可不能分心。我隐约记得。不管怎样，听着，我们可
want to be talking about Indiana Jones when we're talking about Julius. Well, Robert. He was called Robert Oppenheimer. And Oppenheimer is... So the film, the Christopher Nolan film, is by a book, which won the Pulitzer Prize, called American Prometheus by Kai Bird and Martin J. Sherwin. American Prometheus, that will appeal to you, Tom, because Prometheus is the fellow who steals fire and brings it from Zeus as a gift to mankind, doesn't he? But then is punished for it. So what happens to Prometheus? He gets chained to a rock in the Caucasus mountains and either an eagle or vulture, depending on the myth, comes and rips out his guts and then they grow back. And then next day,
不想在谈论尤利乌斯时扯到《夺宝奇兵》。好吧，罗伯特。他叫罗伯特·奥本海默。奥本海默是……所以这部电影，克里斯托弗·诺兰的电影，是根据凯·伯德（Kai Bird）和马丁·J·舍温（Martin J. Sherwin）合著的、获得普利策奖的传记书《美国普罗米修斯》（American Prometheus）改编的。《美国普罗米修斯》，这一定会吸引你，汤姆，因为普罗米修斯就是那个偷取火种并从宙斯那里将其作为礼物带给人类的家伙，不是吗？但随后他为此受到了惩罚。那么普罗米修斯遭遇了什么？他被锁在高加索山的岩石上，根据神话的不同，要么是一只老鹰，要么是一只秃鹫，会来啄食他的内脏，然后内脏又会重新长出来。接着第二天，
the eagle or straight vulture comes back and does the same. And so it goes on until finally Heracles comes and shoots the eagle-straight vulture. Right. But that idea of somebody who has stolen something that is at once exciting, invigorating, liberating, but also utterly terrifying, which is fire, and taking something that should properly belong to the gods and giving it to human beings, and then is punished for it, and then becomes a kind of martyr. That's the core of Oppenheimer's story. I mean, the ancient myth that Oppenheimer himself famously invokes is from the Mahabharata, the great Indian epic, and specifically the Bhagavad Gita. Yes. So it's traditionally said that he sees the atom bomb, and he quotes the Bhagavad Gita,
那只鹰或直来直去的秃鹫又回来做同样的事。就这样周而复始，直到最后赫拉克勒斯（Heracles）来把那只鹰兼秃鹫给射死了。没错。但那种偷走了某种既令人兴奋、振奋、解放，又极其可怕的东西——也就是火——并将本该属于神明的东转移给人类，随后因此受罚，并最终成为某种烈士的想法，正是奥本海默故事的核心。我的意思是，奥本海默本人最喜欢引用的古代神话来自《摩诃婆罗多》，这部印度史诗，特别是《薄伽梵歌》。是的。所以传统上说，他看到了原子弹爆炸，并引用了《薄伽梵歌》中的话，
now I am become death, the destroyer of worlds. But didn't he actually, he actually quoted a couple of lines, if the radiance of a thousand suns were to burst at once into the sky, that would be like the splendor of the mighty one. So in those two quotes, both of which I've seen attributed to him, on the one hand, there's the sense of death and on the other, there's the sense of radiance and light. Yeah. And that ambivalence, by the way, is at the center of his relationship with the atom bomb and with the nuclear age and the Cold War and all those kinds of things, as we'll go on to discuss. And actually, the stories that are told about him, the reason we didn't start with that
“现在我成了死神，世界的毁灭者”。但难道他实际上，他实际引用的是另外几行吗：“如果成千上万个太阳的光芒同时在天空中炸裂，那将犹如万神之尊的光辉。”所以在这两句引言中——我都见过有人说这是他说的——一方面是死亡的感觉，另一方面是光芒和光明的感觉。是的。顺便说一句，这种矛盾心理正是他与原子弹、核时代以及冷战等种种事物之间关系的核心，我们接下来会讨论这一点。事实上，关于他的种种传说——我们之所以不以那个故事开头，
story is I don't think he did say that, because he claims later that he said it, but people at the time don't recall him saying it. But I mean, he studied Sanskrit. I mean, we are talking about one of the cleverest men who seems ever to have lived. I mean, this is a guy who turns up to the Netherlands, not speaking Dutch and gives a lecture in Dutch. He did indeed. I mean, it's an unbelievably clever guy. So maybe he muttered it in Sanskrit. I think the truth of it is he says he said it to himself or he thought it. I wonder whether there's a little bit of the es esprit de scalier there you know that's possibly um it would have been great if i had said this so i'll say that i did um but no so
是因为我觉得他根本没说过那句话，因为他后来声称自己说过，但当时在场的人都不记得他说过。不过我的意思是，他学过梵语。我的意思是，我们谈论的是似乎有史以来最聪明的人之一。我的意思是，这家伙去到荷兰，不会说荷兰语却能用荷兰语做讲座。他确实这么做了。我的意思是，这是一个聪明得令人难以置信的家伙。所以也许他是用梵语咕哝的吧。我认为真相是，他说他对自己说了这句话，或者他心里这么想。我不知道这其中是否有点“楼梯回话”的意味，你知道的，也就是“我要是当时说了这话该多好，所以我现在说我当时说过”；但不是的，所以
the oppenheimer story is not just the story of as you say one of the titanic intellects of the 20th century and somebody who as you also said was the is the godfather or indeed the father of the atomic age but it's also a kind of thriller actually, Tom, because Oppenheimer becomes in the 1950s, the supreme martyr, the sacrificial victim in the McCarthyite anti-communist Red Scare's hysteria of the 1950s. That's what makes his story such an exciting one. Because the context for that is, of course, that it's the United States that gets the atom bomb. Yeah. But the United States is facing a rival superpower that is also after the atom bomb.
奥本海默的故事不仅仅是关于——正如你所说——20世纪泰坦般的智者之一的故事，也是关于一个正如你也说过的那样是原子时代教父或实际之父的人的故事，但实际上它也是某种惊悚片，汤姆，因为在20世纪50年代，奥本海默成为了麦卡锡主义反共“红色恐慌”歇斯底里中的终极烈士、牺牲品。这就是为什么他的故事如此惊心动魄。因为这里的背景当然是，美国得到了原子弹。是的。但美国面临着一个同样在追求原子弹的超级大国竞争对手。
And so the knowledge, this Promethean knowledge, is something very, very prized. Well, right from the start of the Manhattan Project, there was a sense of a race. So initially, that race is against Nazi Germany. But then, as time goes on that race starts to become a race for the soviet union to stay ahead of the soviet union that becomes you know that sort of sense of urgency that sense of tremendous excitement is there throughout oppenheimer's story so let's kick off by tom by talking about oppenheimer himself the man because he is an extraordinary man he's born in April 1904, and he is the child
所以这种知识，这种普罗米修斯式的知识，是非常非常珍贵的。好吧，从曼哈顿计划一开始，就有一种竞赛感。所以最初，这场竞赛是针对纳粹德国的。但随后，随着时间的推移，这场竞赛开始变成与苏联的竞赛，为了领先于苏联，那种紧迫感、那种巨大的兴奋感，在奥本海默的整个故事中始终存在。那么汤姆，让我们从奥本海默本人开始讲起，讲讲这个人，因为他是一个非凡的人，他出生于1904年4月，他是一个
of German Jewish immigrants. Actually, a lot of the people in this story will be of German Jewish immigrant stock, actually. So they're ethnically and they're culturally Jewish, but they're not observant. They don't go to the synagogue or anything like that. His father, Julius, was born in Frankfurt. He's a real autodidact. He spends all his spare time going to art galleries in New York City and reading history books and things. And he worked as a partner in a clothing firm, which sounds very unglamorous, but he's enormously rich. Because he has three Van Goghs and a Picasso. He does, and a Rembrandt, and a Renoir, and a Cezanne. That's not bad, is it?
德国犹太移民的孩子。事实上，这个故事中的许多人实际上都具有德国犹太移民的血统。所以他们在种族和文化上是犹太人，但他们并不恪守教规。他们不去犹太会堂或做诸如此类的事。他的父亲尤利乌斯出生在法兰克福。他是一个真正的自学成才者。他把所有的空闲时间都用来去纽约市的艺术馆，阅读历史书之类的东西。他曾是一家服装公司的合伙人，听起来很不高大上，但他极其富有。因为他拥有三幅梵高的画作和一幅毕加索的画作。他确实有，还有一幅伦勃朗、一幅雷诺阿和一幅塞尚。这很厉害，不是吗？
This is very good going. And they live on the Upper West Side, I think, in New York City. His wife is Ella Friedman. She's a painter. She's also from a sort of German Jewish immigrant stock. And they're very well off. They have a summer house on Long Island where their little boy, Robert, goes sailing. So in other words, they're not a sort of your Lower East Side kind of struggling Jewish immigrant family, quite the reverse.
这发展得相当不错。我想他们住在纽约市的上西区。他的妻子是艾拉·弗里德曼（Ella Friedman）。她是一名画家。她也出身于某种德国犹太移民血统。他们非常富裕。他们在长岛有一栋避暑别墅，他们的小男孩罗伯特会在那里玩帆船。换句话说，他们可不是那种曼哈顿下城苦苦挣扎的犹太移民家庭，恰恰相反。
And not surprisingly, given that he's surrounded by very cerebral parents who spend all the time going to art galleries, Robert, their son, is a very clever little boy. And his passions, so Kai Bird and Martin Sherwin tell us, were poetry, an unusual interest for somebody who's sort of 8, 9, 10 years old, reading and writing poetry. Building things with blocks, which is a sign of the scientific mentality, I suppose, the sort of patterns and construction and all this sort of stuff. And minerals, Tom. So he loves collecting minerals. Do you like minerals? I prefer fossils. Well, I know you're big on fossils. I don't know whether fossils and minerals are part of the same world.
毫不奇怪，鉴于他身边都是花大量时间去艺术馆的极具头脑的父母，他们的儿子罗伯特是一个非常聪明的小男孩。凯·伯德和马丁·舍温告诉我们，他的爱好是诗歌——对于一个八、九、十岁左右、正在阅读和写诗的孩子来说，这是一个不寻常的兴趣。用积木搭东西，我想这标志着一种科学的心态，那种图案、结构以及诸如此类的事情。还有矿物，汤姆。所以他喜欢收集矿物。你喜欢矿物吗？我更喜欢化石。好吧，我知道你对化石很有研究。我不知道化石和矿物是不是属于同一个世界。
I think, yeah. Kind of geological treasures, yeah. Who was Wilfred Owen, the war poet? He was a massive mineralologist, if that's the word. Was he? Well, I did not know that. So he must have enjoyed his trench. And also poetry.
我想，是的。某种地质宝藏，是的。战争诗人威尔弗雷德·欧文（Wilfred Owen）是谁？他是一个狂热的矿物学家，如果这是这个词的话。是吗？好吧，我还真不知道。所以他一定很喜欢他的战壕。还有诗歌。
So he and Oppenheimer would have gone on famously, Tom. Yeah, but Wilfred Owen, he wasn't great on theoretical physics, was he? Not so good, no. And also, of course, was dead by the time that Oppenheimer entered his prime. That would inhibit the flow of conversation. It would. So all through his career, there was a sense of political idealism because his parents were into this thing called the Ethical Culture Society, which is fascinating actually. So that
所以他和奥本海默一定会非常合得来，汤姆。是的，但威尔弗雷德·欧文，他在理论物理学上可不在行，对吧？不太行，是的。而且当然，在奥本海默进入全盛时期时，他已经去世了。这会阻碍对话的流畅性。确实如此。所以在他的整个职业生涯中，都有一种政治理想主义的感觉，因为他的父母参与了一项名为“伦理文化协会”（Ethical Culture Society）的事业，这其实非常迷人。所以
was founded in 1876 and it was founded out of kind of reformed Judaism in New York City by a guy called Felix Adler. And he said, this is the Judaism of the future. We won't have any prayers. We won't have any religious rituals. It's kind of Jewish Quakerism. Jewish Quakerism. Jewish Quakerism. It's very social gospel. It's very about being kind and all that sort of stuff. And you can see why it would appeal because at a point when there's quite a lot of anti-Semitism for basically rich Jewish businessmen in New York who have a social conscience, this is
那是于1876年由一个叫菲利克斯·阿德勒（Felix Adler）的人在纽约市从改良犹太教中创立的。他说，这是未来的犹太教。我们不要任何祈祷。我们不要任何宗教仪式。这有点像犹太教的贵格会主义。犹太教的贵格会主义。犹太教的贵格会主义。它非常具有社会福音色彩。它非常强调善良和诸如此类的事情。你可以理解为什么它会吸引人，因为在一个纽约富裕犹太商人普遍存在相当多反犹太主义且具有社会良知的时刻，这是一种
a way, it's a sort of assimilationist creed. So they can join in life, they can have clubs, they can do stuff, but their Jewishness is kind of downplayed. They are all Jewish, but they're not talking about the Torah and stuff. And there's this kind of liberal activist element to it. So Oppenheimer goes to this school and he is by far the kind of top student. He's the brain box, top of his class and everything. But even at this point, and this will recur throughout his career, he's a very awkward kind of lonely person. So there's a story that when he's 14, his parents sent him to summer camp. You know, obviously, most of our American listeners will be very familiar with the idea of summer camps for non-Americans.
方式，是一种同化主义信条。这样他们就可以融入生活，加入俱乐部，做各种事情，但他们的犹太身份被某种程度上淡化了。他们都是犹太人，但他们不谈论托拉之类的事。其中有一种自由主义激进分子的元素。所以奥本海默就读于这所学校，他是当之无愧的顶级学生。他是大脑瓜，班里的第一名等等。但即使在这一点上——而且这将在他的整个职业生涯中屡次出现——他也是一个非常笨拙、孤独的人。所以有个故事说，当他14岁时，他的父母把他送去了夏令营。你知道，显然，我们的许多美国听众会非常熟悉夏令营的概念，对于非美国人来说，
You know, this is a huge ritual for American kids. It's probably not really matched. It doesn't have any counterpart in other countries. So he goes to summer camp. And it's all sports and games and kind of Boy Scout-ish kind of activities in which he doesn't really join in at all. He just walks around collecting rocks. And he's also, like most normal 14-year-olds, he's completely obsessed with George Eliot, Tom. Yes, of course.
你知道，这是美国孩子的一项重大仪式。它在其他国家可能没有真正的对应物，没有同类事物。所以他去了夏令营。那里全都是体育运动、游戏和某种童子军式的活动，而他根本不参与其中。他只是四处走来走去收集石头。而且，像大多数正常的14岁少年一样，他完全迷恋上了乔治·艾略特（George Eliot），汤姆。是的，当然。
What young lad going off to summer camp doesn't want to curl up with Mill on the floor? He's really into Middlemarch. So people are saying, you know... Oh, even longer novel. How do you think the Yankees are going to get on this season? He says, well, you know, I'm just thinking about Dorothea or whatever it is.
哪个去夏令营的年轻小伙不想卷起毯子在地板上读《弗洛斯河上的磨坊》呢？他非常迷恋《米德尔马契》。所以人们在说……哦，更长的小说。你觉得洋基队这个赛季会表现得怎么样？他说，好吧，你知道，我只是在想多萝西娅或者诸如此类的事。
Anyway, he writes home to his parents. He says, well, it's not actually going that badly because one good thing about going is my campmates have taught me all about the facts of life. And his parents are outraged. They write to the camp sort of top brass who give the boys a massive rollicking. The boys then,
无论如何，他写信回家给父母。他说，其实情况没有那么糟，因为去那里的一大好处是，我的营友们教会了我关于生命真相（生理知识）的一切。他的父母大发雷霆。他们写信给夏令营的高层，高层把这群男孩狠狠训斥了一番。然后这群男孩，
do you know what they do to Oppenheimer? It's not good, Tom. They strip him. They paint his buttocks and genitals with green paint, and they lock him overnight in an ice house. But I'm afraid, Dominic, that if you are the kind of child who goes around reading Middlemarch, that's what you've got to expect. Tom, that is harsh.
你知道他们对奥本海默做了什么吗？这可不太妙，汤姆。他们扒光了他的衣服。他们用绿色的颜料涂抹他的臀部和生殖器，把他反锁在一个冰库里过夜。但我恐怕，多米尼克，如果你是那种到处抱着《米德尔马契》读的孩子，那你这就是自找的。汤姆，这也太残酷了。
I speak from personal experience. That is... What? Has that ever happened to you? I'm not going to say. Crikey. Well, that is very harsh. I didn't expect such ruthlessness on the rest of his history, to be honest. Anyway. You've just got to man up.
我是根据个人经验来说的。这太……什么？这种事发生在你身上过？我无可奉告。天哪。好吧，这确实太残酷了说实话，我没想到《历史的余烬》节目里会有这种冷酷无情。不管怎样。你只能硬着头皮接受。
Well, so Oppenheimer, and this will also disappoint you, Tom. He graduated in 1921, and he had a place at Harvard, not surprisingly. But then he went off with his family on a little trip to holiday to Germany before going to Harvard, and he fell ill. He fell ill while prospecting for minerals. Do you know, I love him. His parents said, oh, you've fallen ill. You'll have to defer at Harvard for a year while you stay at home and have improving broths and we look after you. But actually, one thing that does happen, which is related to the nuclear issue, go on, I'm intrigued to know where this is leading. As part of his convalescence,
好吧，所以奥本海默——这也一定会让你失望，汤姆。他在1921年毕业，毫无疑问，他在哈佛拿到了一个名额。但随后他和家人在去哈佛之前去德国进行了一次小小的度假旅行，结果他生病了。他在勘探矿物时生病了。你知道吗，我太喜欢他了。他父母说，哦，你生病了。你得把哈佛入学推迟一年，呆在家里喝点有营养的肉汤，我们照顾你。但事实上，确实发生了一件事，这和核问题有关。说吧，我很好奇这会通向何方。作为他康复治疗的一部分，
they arranged for one of his teachers, a man called Herbert Smith, from this sort of improving ethical reform, whatever it is, Ethical Culture Society School, to take him to New Mexico, riding. He falls in love with riding. And one day he's riding near Santa Fe and he sees this valley. And in the valley or the top of the valley, there is a boys school, a boarding school. And is this school by any chance called Los Alamos? It is. It is, Tom. It is called Los Alamos.
他们安排了他的一位老师——一个名叫赫伯特·史密斯（Herbert Smith）的人，来自那种励志伦理改良学校，也就是伦理文化协会学校——带他去新墨西哥州骑马。他爱上了骑马。有一天，他在圣达菲附近骑马时，看到了这个山谷。在山谷里或山谷的顶部，有一所男子学校，一所寄宿学校。这所学校该不会叫洛斯阿拉莫斯吧？是的。正是如此，汤姆。它就叫洛斯阿拉莫斯。
What an extraordinary moment. Yeah. So he sees this and he thinks, brilliant place for a nuclear test. And then he comes back. I'll be back. Yeah. I'll be back. Yeah, I'll be back, exactly. He does go to Harvard. His biographers describe him as a studious, socially inept and immature young man,
多么不可思议的时刻。是的。所以他看到了这个，心想：这是进行核试验的绝佳地点。然后他回来了。我会回来的。对。我会回来的。是的，我一定会回来的，没错。他确实上了哈佛。他的传记作家将他描述为一个用功、社交无能且不成熟的年轻人，
which is very nice. He's very austere. So he's a complete boffin. Here for dinner every night, he has chocolate, beer and artichokes. And do you know what he has for lunch? He has something he calls black and tan, which is toast covered with peanut butter and chocolate syrup. So he's not a man for a healthy diet, it's fair to say. But he's very thin, isn't he? Incredibly thin. Incredibly thin.
这评价很客气。他非常简朴。所以他是个十足的书呆子。每天晚上来吃晚饭时，他都吃巧克力、啤酒和洋蓟。你知道他午饭吃什么吗？他吃一种叫“黑与白”的食物，也就是涂了花生酱和巧克力糖浆的吐司。所以可以说，他绝对不是一个崇尚健康饮食的人。但他很瘦，对吧？瘦骨嶙峋。瘦骨嶙峋。
He's a chain smoker. He's a chain smoker. He's very melancholy. He's very moody. And Tom, one of the great highlights of doing the rest of this issue is we get to read wonderful works of poetry. And I thought you'd enjoy it if I read some of J. Robert Oppenheimer, Father of the great highlights of doing the rest of this issue is we get to read wonderful works of poetry. And I thought you'd enjoy it if I read some of J. Robert Oppenheimer, father of the nuclear bombs, poems, his erotic poems. Would you like to hear that? Yes, yes, yes, please. Okay. This is informed by the fact of life that he's been tortured in summer camp. Precisely.
他是个老烟枪。他是个老烟枪。他非常忧郁。非常喜怒无常。汤姆，制作《历史的余烬》节目的一大亮点就是我们能读到精彩的诗歌作品。我想如果你能听我朗读一些 J·罗伯特·奥本海默——制作《历史的余烬》节目的一大亮点就是我们能读到精彩的诗歌作品。我想如果你能听我朗读一些 J·罗伯特·奥本海默——这位伟大核弹之父的诗歌，他的情诗——你一定会喜欢的。你想听吗？好，好，好，请吧。好的。这是由他在夏令营遭受虐待的生命经历所启发的。准确地说。
He's never had any dealings, as far as I can tell at this point. I don't think he's even spoken to a girl or a woman. So he says, I'm going to find this quite hard to read because they're ludicrous. Tonight she wears a seal skin cape, glistening black diamonds where the water sways her thighs.
据我所能了解到的，他在此之前从未与人有过任何交往。我觉得他甚至都没有跟女孩或女人说过话。所以他说，我发现这很难读，因为它们太荒谬了。今晚她穿着海豹皮斗篷，当水波摇曳她的双腿时，那里闪烁着黑色的钻石。
A noxious glint conspire to surprise, a pulse condoning eagerness with rape. That's unexpected, isn't it? You didn't expect that final word. I did not expect that. This was inspired by Spinoza, an erotic poem inspired by Spinoza, the great Dutch.
一种有害的微光密谋着带来惊喜，一种脉搏在强暴中默认着渴望。这出乎意料，不是吗？你没想到最后一个词是这个。我确实没想到。这是受斯宾诺莎的启发，一首受伟大荷兰人斯宾诺莎启发的情诗。
Who will be featuring very soon in our episode on Amsterdam. No, I know that there have been others who have read Spinoza, even I. Others who have crossed their white arms across the umber pages. Others too pure to glance even a second beyond the sacred sphincter of their erudition yeah that is that is unexpected well yeah how old was he when he was writing this about 21 or something
很快我们将在关于阿姆斯特丹的节目中介绍他。不，我知道还有其他人读过斯宾诺莎，甚至连我都读过。其他人把白皙的手臂交叉放在赭色的书页上。其他人纯洁得甚至不愿向他们博学的神圣括约肌之外投以哪怕一秒钟的目光……是的，这确实，这确实出乎意料。好吧，是的，他写这东西的时候多大？大概21岁左右吧？
yeah maybe not even um no he's probably a little bit younger i'm being harsh he's probably about 18 okay but i think that's fair enough yeah they are you didn't expect that no i didn't expect that yeah maybe not even no he's probably a little bit younger i'm being harsh he's probably about 18 okay i think that's fair enough yeah they are you didn't expect that no i didn't expect that probably science more his thing then well yes it is he does very well he's actually studying chemistry but he falls in love with physics and after this he goes off to england to study at the cavendish lab in cambridge which is the great place for quantum physics but he's very clumsy isn't he he's well he's clumsy and very unpopular and so ernest rutherford refuses to have him correct on his team because he keeps knocking over test tubes exactly so quantum physics for
是的，也许甚至没有……不，他可能还要更年轻一些，我有点苛求了，他大概18岁吧。好吧，但我觉得这很公平，是的。它们就是，你没想到吧？不，我没想到。是的，也许甚至没有……不，他可能还要更年轻一些，我有点苛求了，他大概18岁吧。好吧，但我觉得这很公平，是的。它们就是，你没想到吧？不，我没想到。可能科学更适合他吧？嗯，确实如此。他做得很好。他最初其实学的是化学，但他爱上了物理学，在此之后他前往英国，在剑桥的卡文迪许实验室学习，那是量子物理学的伟大圣地。但他非常笨拙，不是吗？嗯，他既笨拙又极不受欢迎，所以欧内斯特·卢瑟福（Ernest Rutherford）拒绝让他加入自己的团队，因为他总是撞翻试管。没错，所以量子物理学——对于
those people who don't know it's the laws that govern basically atoms molecules electrons there's going to be a lot of science in this time and i have really ginned up on it so um he's very miserable in um in cambridge he doesn't really like england he behaves in a series of ludicrous ways so that the erotic stuff is there's clearly a lot going on there there's a story that he was once in a third class railway carriage and there were two people opposite him a man and a woman who were kissing and they were obviously boyfriend and girlfriend or husband and wife the man went out to probably buy some cigarettes or something and at that point oppenheimer threw himself on the woman and kissed her.
那些不太了解的人来说——就是支配原子、分子、电子的基本定律。这次节目里会有很多科学内容，我为此恶补了一番。所以他在剑桥过得很悲惨，他真的不喜欢英国，他的行为荒谬透顶，那些情色内容说明当时他内心显然有很多波澜。有个故事说，有一次他在一个三等火车的车厢里，对面坐着两个人，一男一女在接吻，他们显然是男女朋友或夫妻。那个男的可能下车去买烟什么的，就在那个时候，奥本海默扑向那个女人并亲吻了她。
She pushed him off. And then he fell to the ground sobbing in a sort of terrible heap. And the fact that he then went around telling people this story suggests that he wasn't, you know. So he's a faintly rapey nerd. Correct. He tried to kill his tutor, a man called Patrick Blackett, by poisoning an apple and leaving it in the laboratory for him to eat. Wow.
她把他推开了。然后他倒在地上，像一团痛苦的烂泥一样啜泣。事实上，他后来还到处跟人讲这个故事，这表明他……所以他是一个略带性侵倾向的书呆子。没错。他试图杀死他的导师——一个叫帕特里克·布莱克特（Patrick Blackett）的人，方法是在一个苹果里下毒，然后把它留在实验室里让他吃。哇。
That's very Snow White. It's very Snow White. And then the other thing. Presumably, was Snow White coming out at that time? Maybe he was inspired by it. I don't think so, Tom. I think Snow White is a little bit later, about 10 years later. He had a friend called Francis Ferguson, who was a Rhodes Scholar.
这太“白雪公主”了。这太“白雪公主”了。还有另一件事。大概吧，当时《白雪公主》上映了吗？也许他是受了启发。我觉得不是，汤姆。我觉得《白雪公主》要稍微晚一点，大概晚了10年。他有一个朋友叫弗朗西斯·弗格森（Francis Ferguson），是个罗德学者。
And Francis Ferguson said to him one day, great news. I've got engaged to my girlfriend. And oppenheimer sort of smiled weakly and then when francis ferguson turned his back i'm a left on him with the strap from a trunk and tried to strangle him tried to garrot him and then when ferguson fought him off a bit like on the train oppenheimer then fell to the floor and floods of tears he sounds sounds quite creepy. Yeah, he is quite creepy. So he then went to Germany to Göttingen, which is the great center of theoretical physics. So as you said, Cambridge, you need to be good with test tubes. This is experimental.
有一天，弗朗西斯·弗格森对他说：“好消息。我跟女朋友订婚了。”奥本海默勉强笑了笑，然后趁弗朗西斯·弗格森转过身去，他用一个皮箱的带子勒住弗格森，试图勒死他，试图用绞索勒他。当弗格森像在火车上那样挣扎着反抗时，奥本海默随后倒在地板上痛哭流涕。他听起来，听起来真让人毛骨悚然。是的，他确实挺让人毛骨悚然的。所以他后来去了德国的哥廷根，那是理论物理学的伟大中心。正如你所说，在剑桥，你需要擅长使用试管。那是实验性的。
In Göttingen, it's all kind of more mathematical. But there, he was so unpopular, interrupting in the class the whole time, that the other students boycotted the course unless he was removed. And was he i think he probably he was or they found a way around it but didn't he became friends with um verner heisenberg well he's not really friends with heisenberg no but there is it's true that this is the point at which verner heisenberg dominic tell people who've done so verner heisenberg is oppenheimer's kind of rival to some degree. He is one of the absolute meteoric figures of the golden age of breakthroughs in quantum physics, the high point of which is between 1925 and 1927. And all these theoretical physics boffins are studying the movement of electrons around the nucleus of an atom.
在哥廷根，一切都更具数学性。但在那里，他极其不受欢迎，在课堂上总是不断插话，以至于其他学生发起联合抵制，除非把他开除，否则就不去上这门课。而且确实……我想他可能，他确实被……或者他们找到了解决办法，但难道他没有和沃纳·海森堡（Werner Heisenberg）成为朋友吗？嗯，他跟海森堡其实并不是朋友，但确实，这是沃纳·海森堡——多米尼克，给听众们介绍一下——所以沃纳·海森堡在某种程度上可以说是奥本海默的竞争对手。他是量子物理学黄金时代中那些星光熠熠的传奇人物之一，这一黄金时代的巅峰期在1925年到1927年之间。所有这些理论物理学书呆子都在研究原子核周围电子的运动。
Tom, something I know you're very familiar with. And of course, Heisenberg, Tom, you all know this. Yeah, his uncertainty principle. The uncertainty principle. So more precisely, the more exactly you know the position of a particle, Tom, the less, of course, you can predict its momentum. You know that, don't you? Yes, I did know that. Good. And it's an incredibly exciting field. It's very much a young man's field. So Einstein is kind of yesterday's man, really. And all these young, thrusting young fellows are studying electrons and talking about waves and all this kind of business.
汤姆，我知道你对这个非常熟悉。当然，海森堡，汤姆，你们都知道这个。是的，他的测不准原理。测不准原理。更准确地说，汤姆，你对一个粒子的位置了解得越精确，当然，你就越无法预测它的动量。你知道这个，对吧？是的，我确实知道。很好。这是一个令人兴奋得难以置信的领域。这很大程度上是年轻人的领域。所以爱因斯坦基本上算是个过气人物了。所有这些年轻气盛的小伙子都在研究电子，谈论波以及所有这类事情。
And Oppenheimer, he published 16 papers in three years. So he's a great kind of, you know, people know that he's an absolute star of this stuff. Before coming on to do this, I did some research in the Bodleian, where I read that his achievements in physics include the Born-Oppenheimer approximation for molecular wave functions, Dominic. Wave functions is one of his things, and field emissions, Tom. Did you read it? But did Wikipedia tell you about his work on field emissions? No, it didn't. But I was just wondering, what exactly is... So tell the listeners what the approximation for molecular wave functions is all about.
而奥本海默，他在三年内发表了16篇论文。所以他是一个非常了不起的……人们知道他是这方面的绝对明星。在来录制这个节目之前，我在博德利图书馆（Bodleian）做了一些研究，我读到他在物理学方面的成就包括用于分子波函数的玻恩-奥本海默近似，多米尼克。波函数是他的研究成果之一，还有场致发射，汤姆。你读过这个吗？维基百科有没有告诉你关于他关于场致发射的研究？不，它没有。但我只是在想，这到底是什么……所以给听众们讲讲关于分子波函数的近似到底是怎么回事吧。
I'll be very happy to do so. But we'll be doing that, Tom, for members of the Restless History Club. You can sign up at restlesshistorypod.com. Restless particle physics. I don't want to waste it on the ordinary listeners. Okay. No, that's fair enough. So he gets a job, anyway, in the long run at the University of California at Berkeley. And is he... So Heisenberg is very much Germany's top boffin.
我非常乐意效劳。但汤姆，我们要为“历史的余烬俱乐部”的会员们详细讲解这个。你可以在 restlesshistorypod.com 注册加入。“余烬粒子物理学”。我可不想在普通听众身上浪费这个。好吧。不，这倒也合理。不管怎样，他最终在加州大学伯克利分校找到了一份工作。那么他是……所以海森堡可以说是德国的顶级书呆子。
Yeah. Is Oppenheimer already being groomed to be America's top boffin? I don't think he's being groomed as the top boffin because there are lots of top boffins in America. But he's a top boffin. He is a top boffin, exactly. In the American Prometheus book, the Byrd and Sherwin book, they call him the Pied Piper of theoretical physics. So if you are clever and you are 18, you might well want to go and study with Oppenheimer.
对。奥本海默当时已经在被当作美国的顶级书呆子来培养吗？我觉得他并没有被当作顶级书呆子来培养，因为美国有很多顶级书呆子。但他是一个顶级书呆子。他确实是个顶级书呆子，没错。在《美国普罗米修斯》那本书里，伯德和舍温称他为理论物理学的“吹笛手”。所以如果你很聪明，而且正好18岁，你很可能会想去跟奥本海默一起学习。
You'd go to what's called, so it's the Berkeley Radiation Lab, but it's actually nicknamed the Rad Lab. And as we will see, that has another dimension, the Rad Lab. But just on Oppenheimer, before we get back to the Rad element of the Rad Lab, he's still quite an awkward, lonely, cerebral man.
你会去那个叫伯克利辐射实验室的地方，但它通常被称为“Rad Lab”（辐射实验室）。正如我们将会看到的，“Rad Lab”还有另一层含义。但就奥本海默而言，在我们回到 Rad Lab 的 Rad（酷/激进）元素之前，他仍然是一个有些尴尬、孤独、极具头脑的人。
The key question, Dominic. Yeah. Has he actually managed to speak to a woman at this point? I don't think so, really. He will do soon. And a very important moment at that. I heard like, do you like electrons yeah is that how he speaks i imagine that's exactly how he speaks as you said he taught himself he does things like
关键问题，多米尼克。是的。他此时此刻真的成功跟女人说过话了吗？我觉得还没有，真的。他很快就会了。那将是一个非常关键的时刻。我听到像，“嗨，你喜欢电子吗？”是的，他是这么说话的吗？我猜他就是这么说话的。正如你所说，他自学了
teaching himself dutch he spends all his time reading sanskrit yeah reading um sort of sacred texts hindu texts and things and then in the holidays he goes off and he rides in new mexico with his brother frank they will ride a thousand miles in a summer you know across the kind of the plateaus and the valleys so he's not just a nerd no he's not but he's also not a man who would spend his summer lounging on a sofa with a gin and tonic yeah okay so he wouldn't he wouldn't go to mallorca he would not he's a very driven man now i said it was the rad lab and when he gets to berkeley so we're at the sort of late 20s into the early and mid 1930s, it's a real hotbed of radical politics. So the Rad Lab is kind of double edged. And he goes to parties with other academics where they all talk about kind of Roosevelt's New Deal, about trade unions, about the rights of migrant farm workers,
像荷兰语这样的语言，他把所有时间都用来阅读梵语，是的，阅读圣典、印度教文本之类的内容。然后每逢假期，他就和弟弟弗兰克一起去新墨西哥州骑马，他们可以在一个夏天骑行一千里（穿过高原和山谷）。所以他不仅仅是个书呆子，不，他不是，但他也不是那种会在夏天躺在沙发上喝金汤力消磨时光的人，对吧。所以他不会去马略卡岛度假，绝不会。他是一个非常有拼劲的人。现在我刚才提到了“Rad Lab”，当他来到伯克利时——也就是20年代末到30年代初和中期——那里是激进政治的真正温床。所以 Rad Lab 具有双重含义。他去参加其他学者的派对，在那里大家都谈论罗斯福的新政、工会、农场移民工人的权利，
all this sort of stuff that is absolutely in the air on the West Coast in the 30s. I also read in the Bodleian that he claimed only to have heard about the Wall Street crash six months after it happened. But that's very plausible. Yeah. But that seems to contradict the sense of him as someone who's very interested in radical politics. Well, first of all, the Wall Street crash happens at the beginning of his time. So do you think he becomes increasingly interested in politics?
所有这些在30年代的西海岸无处不在的事情。我还曾在博德利图书馆读到，他声称自己直到华尔街股灾发生六个月后才知道这件事。但这非常符合情理。是的。但那似乎与他作为一个对激进政治非常感兴趣的人的形象相矛盾。首先，华尔街股灾发生在他那段时期的开始。所以你认为他对政治越来越感兴趣了吗？
He does absolutely. At first, I think he's idealistic, but unworldly. And then he becomes worldlier. I think there are a couple of people. One is a very important person in his story, who is a professor of French called Joaquin Chevalier. And Chevalier has these kind of parties and salons such as his house where people get together and they talk about left-wing ideas. This is kind of standard stuff in the academic world in the 1930s. But as we will see, this will have absolutely tumultuous consequences for Oppenheimer's career and his reputation. And the other person, he meets a medical student called Jean Tatlock. She's played in the film by Florence Pugh.
他的确如此。起初，我认为他是理想主义的，但脱离实际的。然后他变得更加通晓世故了。我认为有几个人很重要。其中一个在他的故事中非常重要，是一位名叫若阿尚·舍瓦利耶（Joaquin Chevalier）的法国文学教授。舍瓦利耶会在他的家里举办各种派对和沙龙，人们聚在一起讨论左翼思想。这在20世纪30年代的学术界是标准操作。但正如我们将看到的，这将会给奥本海默的职业生涯和声誉带来天翻地覆的后果。另一个人，他遇到了一位名叫琼·塔特洛克（Jean Tatlock）的医学生。她在电影中由弗洛伦斯·皮尤（Florence Pugh）扮演。
Tom, that gives you some sense of her. Oh, I love Florence Pugh. Yeah, well, there you go. Whose dad runs a restaurant in Oxford. He's always moaning about chairs. He's not allowed to put chairs outside his restaurant. And also very furious about traffic calming measures in Oxford, which apparently have depressed demand for his business.
汤姆，这能让你对她有个概念。哦，我很喜欢弗洛伦斯·皮尤。对，你看，就是这样。她的父亲在牛津开了一家餐馆。他总是抱怨椅子。他不被允许把椅子摆在餐馆外面。而且他对牛津的交通减速措施也非常愤怒，这些措施显然压低了他的生意需求。
That is not a line I expected us to be taking in this episode. Right, she is the daughter, Florence Pugh, a.k.a. Jean Tatlock. She is the daughter of a notable Chaucer scholar, Tom, which would appeal to you. She'd studied English lit at Vassar, the great college for sort of rich, posh girls. And she had been a very keen member since her teens, late teens, of the Communist Party, Tom.
这可不是我预计我们在本集中会出现的台词。好吧，她是弗洛伦斯·皮尤的化身，也就是琼·塔特洛克。汤姆，她是一位著名乔叟学者的女儿，这一定会吸引你。她曾在瓦萨学院（Vassar）——那所专为富裕、高贵女孩设立的伟大大学——学习英国文学。而且从十几岁、十七八岁开始，她就是英国共产党的一名极其热心的成员，汤姆。
Right. So she went to two Communist Party meetings religiously every week. And she wrote to a friend, I am a complete red. And she and Oppenheimer basically strike up this great romance. So he now definitely has spoken to a girl. Is this his first real experience of relating to women in a way that doesn't involve?
没错。所以她每周雷打不动地去参加两次共产党的会议。她曾给一个朋友写信说：“我是一个彻头彻尾的红派。”她和奥本海默基本上就此展开了一场伟大的恋爱。所以他现在绝对跟女孩说过话了。这是他第一次真正体验到与女性建立联系，而且这种联系不涉及……
Strangling people or crying. Basically. Basically, a relationship with a woman that is, I mean, it must be overwhelming for him because he's obviously got very, very intense sexual feelings. Yeah. But at the same time, it hasn't had any way of expressing them. Yeah, I think that's right and he meets someone who presumably is you know intellectually empowering and full of new
勒死人或哭泣。基本上就是这样。基本上，与一个女性建立关系——对他的冲击一定巨大无比，因为他显然有着非常非常强烈的主观性欲。是的。但与此同时，他又没有任何表达这种欲望的方式。是的，我想确实如此。他遇到了一位可能在智力上赋予他力量、充满新
ideas so do you think is that a she must be a huge influence on him she is massive influence she's the great love of his life i would say they don't end up marrying she's a little bit she's troubled she suffers very badly from Indeed, she ends up taking her own life much later on after they're no longer an item. But she is a great, great influence on him. But again, I mean, he seems depressive. Yes. Oh, yeah, absolutely. I mean, when he was at, I think in England, people sort of said, you know, you need to seek treatment.
思想的人。所以你认为，她一定是对他产生了巨大的影响。她确实产生了巨大的影响。可以说她是他一生中至爱。他们最终没有结婚。她有些精神困扰，深受……事实上，在他们不再交往很久之后，她最终选择了轻生。但她对他产生了巨大无比的影响。不过话说回来，他自己似乎也饱受抑郁之苦。是的。噢，是的，绝对的。我的意思是，当他在英国时，人们曾对他说：“你需要去寻求治疗。
You are a very troubled, a very troubled man. But in the same year that he met her, he started reading Das Kapital. His father gives him a copy of Sidney and Beatrice Webb's book, Soviet Communism, A New Civilization, which is always the sort of book that people bash the British left with when they say they were soft on communism in the 1930s. I mean, it seems quite odd behavior for a New York plutocrat. Yeah, but he's an idealistic plutocrat, Tom.
你是一个非常痛苦、非常痛苦的人。”但在他遇到她的同一年，他开始阅读《资本论》。他的父亲送了他一本西德尼和比阿特丽斯·韦伯（Sidney and Beatrice Webb）合著的书《苏联共产主义：一种新文明》（Soviet Communism: A New Civilization），这本书总是被用来抨击英国左翼，指责他们在20世纪30年代对共产主义心慈手软。我的意思是，对于一个纽约财阀来说，这举动显得挺奇怪的。是的，但他是一个理想主义的财阀，汤姆。
And it's not only a plutocrat, he's a sort of trouser magnate or whatever. People selling you shirts. I mean, can you be a plutocrat if you're... No, I suppose not. But he's doing well. He's doing very well. He's got a Rembrandt. That's true.
而且他不仅仅是个财阀，他还是个服装大亨还是什么的。卖衬衫的人。我的意思是，如果你是……你能算财阀吗？不，我想不能。但他确实很有钱。他非常有钱。他有一幅伦勃朗的画。这倒也是。
That's true. Okay, fair enough. Semi-plutocrat. So Oppenheimer and Jean, they spend all their time going to these weekly kind of political parties where people sit around and they talk about Jewish refugees from Nazi Germany, the plight of farm workers in Roosevelt's America. They have fundraisers for the Republicans in Spain during the Spanish Civil War. And a lot of these things are genuine causes, but they're also communist
这倒也是。好吧，言之有理。半个财阀。所以奥本海默和琼，他们把所有时间都用来参加这些每周一次的政治派对，人们坐在一起讨论来自纳粹德国的犹太难民、罗斯福的美国境内农场工人的困境。他们为西班牙内战期间西班牙的共和派举办筹款活动。而其中许多事情都是正当的爱国事业，但它们同时也是共产党
front organizations. Now, a lot of the people at these meetings are paid up card-carrying members of the communist party, including Oppenheimer's brother, Frank. Oppenheimer himself seems never to have joined, probably because he's just not very clubbable. He's not a joiner. Because the communists in this period in, say, California, are they kind of left-wing masons? There's a sense of that. It's a club. It's something where you… I think it's a very complicated picture because the American Communist Party
的外围组织。现在，这些会议上的许多人都是共产党交纳党费的正式党员，包括奥本海默的弟弟弗兰克。而奥本海默本人似乎从未入党，大概是因为他这人不太合群。他不爱搞社交。因为这一时期的共产党人——比如说在加利福尼亚——他们有点像左翼的共济会吗？确实有这种感觉。它是一个俱乐部。这是一个你……我觉得情况非常复杂，因为美国共产党
was one of the most Stalinist parties in the world, the CPUSA. But at the same time, as you say, communism is attractive to a whole part of the kind of radical academic intellectual elite but also communist appeals to people in the in the union so the 1930s is a great age of union arrest in america and california california has always been this kind of seedbed for radical ideas so you there's all kinds of motives that would draw people into the party and you know we did a podcast series about ronald reagan we? And we were talking about him in Hollywood in the 1930s and 1940s
是世界上最斯大林主义的政党之一，也就是美共（CPUSA）。但与此同时，正如你所说，共产主义对激进学术知识分子精英阶层的整个群体有着巨大的吸引力，而且共产主义也吸引了工会中的人们。所以20世纪30年代是美国和加利福尼亚工会动荡的伟大时代，加利福尼亚一直以来都是孕育激进思想的温床。所以你会发现，有各种各样的动机把人们吸引进党内。你知道的，我们曾做过一个关于罗纳德·里根的播客系列，对吧？我们在节目中谈到了他在20世纪30年代和40年代在好莱坞的生活，
and the appeal of this kind of radical stuff in Hollywood. I mean, this is actually pretty similar. So people will be drawn into communism because their mates are all in it. As you say, some of them are Stalinists. Some of them are idealists. Some of them, it's a clubbable thing to do and all the people you know are doing it
以及这种激进事物在好莱坞的吸引力。我的意思是，这其实相当相似。所以人们会被吸引加入共产主义，因为他们的朋友都在里面。正如你所说，他们当中有些人是斯大林主义者。有些人是理想主义者。对有些人来说，这只是一种合群的社交活动，而且你认识的所有人都在这么做
and it's a good cause and all this sort of stuff. And he is clearly, it's a clubbable thing to do, and all the people you know are doing it, and it's a good cause, and all this sort of stuff. And he is clearly, he's giving cash. He's not paying membership dues, but he's giving cash donations to communist organizations. And the FBI, even at this point, are aware of all this. So in March 1941, this is before the United States has entered the Second World War, one of their guys is making a note of all the license plates of the people who've been to what this guy Hawkins Chevalier's part is. And Oppenheimer's is one of them. And they open a file on Oppenheimer that month. It's not because of the bomb or because of physics or something. It's because he's just part of that world and they have files on all of these people and because they have a sense war is coming so that is a theme
这是一个伟 and it's a good cause and all this sort of stuff. And he is clearly, it's a clubbable thing to do, and all the people you know are doing it, and it's a good cause, and all this sort of stuff. And he is clearly, he's giving cash. He's not paying membership dues, but he's giving cash donations to communist organizations. And the FBI, even at this point, are aware of all this. So in March 1941, this is before the United States has entered the Second World War, one of their guys is making a note of all the license plates of the people who've been to what this guy Hawkins Chevalier's part is. And Oppenheimer's is one of them. And they open a file on Oppenheimer that month. It's not because of the bomb or because of physics or something. It's because he's just part of that world and they have files on all of these people and because they have a sense war is coming so that is a theme
that we will pursue in the second half yes and of course there'll be more physics so um very exciting we'll be back in a few minutes with with dominic explaining the laws of the universe goodbye chiara it means smart in italian too bad your barista can't spell it right so you just give The laws of the universe. Goodbye. Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this, because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip,
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking Oppenheimer and Dominic. You are, I mean, an astonishing development to all who know your much vaunted hatred of science. You are now all over the development of the atom bomb.
Well, Tom, I never said I wasn't good at science. I said I had no interest in it, which is different. So if I can effortlessly get my way through quantum physics, despite not being interested in it, I should be very proud of myself. And that is an unusual thing, Tom, because as you know, I do suffer from colossally low self-esteem. So 1939, Europe is at war. The big development for Oppenheimer is he splits up with Jean Tatlock, Florence Pugh, and he marries a woman called Kitty Harrison. Now, she's from a rich Pittsburgh family,
but interestingly, she's on a second husband already. Her first husband, believe it or not, was a communist party organizer in the steel town of Youngstown, Ohio. So it's all stacking up. And it even run for mayor, Tom, on the communist ticket. How did he do? Didn't do well. He won about two votes. And he was then killed as a volunteer in the Republican army in Spain. Well, credit to him putting, you know, I mean.
Yeah. He put his money where his mouth was. But yeah. Yeah. So she then, Kitty then married again. She married a British doctor. Then she had an affair with Oppenheimer. Oppenheimer and the doctor kind of got their heads together.
It was all very sort of gentlemanly. And she left the doctor and with Oppenheimer. Oppenheimer and the doctor kind of got their heads together. It was all very sort of gentlemanly. And she left the doctor and married Oppenheimer. She gets a terrible press in all the books about Oppenheimer. People say she's, I mean, the Kai Bird and Martin Sherman book is full of people saying Kitty was a genuinely wicked woman. Oh, goodness. Why? Well, she drank a lot. She was very abrasive. I think there is always an element, though, in these sort of biographies of, in inverted
commas, great men, that sometimes the women or the wives, if they're spirited people, independent people, they come off very badly. Basically, all the hero of the books' friends say, oh, Kitty was a terrible person. She was always moaning when we went out on the, you know. On the lash. On the lash, exactly. Was Oppenheimer going out on the lash? he doesn't seem the kind of person for that no but he was they had a very they clearly had quite a volatile relationship and she was a volatile person was
she a spitfire that's what that's what um in screwball comedies yeah i think would she be played by katherine hepburn that's what you're saying yeah she might be played by katherine hepburn i suppose um yeah i think her enemies would regard that as very generous generous I think, would she be played by Catherine Hepburn? Is that what you're saying? Yeah. She might be played by Catherine Hepburn, I suppose. Yeah, I think her enemies would regard that as very generous casting. I think she's Emily Blunt in the Christopher Nolan film. So, you know, draw your own conclusions, Tom. Emily Blunt was Mary Poppins, wasn't she? Yeah, I don't have any strong, I don't think I've ever seen Emily Blunt in anything,
so I have no strong views on Emily Blunt one way or the other. I mean, I have to say Mary Poppins sounds exactly what Oppenheimer needs yeah I guess so well he didn't you know stopping him strangle people poisoning people with apples all that so let's let's get so let us cut to the chase now Tom so in January 1939 news broke on the west coast that two German physicists Otto Hahn and Fritz Strassmann had demonstrated that you could split the nucleus of uranium which is one of the heaviest elements in the periodic table, if you bombarded it with neutrons, with subatomic particles. The resulting fission will see a gigantic release of energy. And right away, people around the world see that this could produce a bomb the like of which humanity had
so I have no strong views on Emily Blunt one way or the other. I mean, I have to say Mary Poppins sounds exactly what Oppenheimer needs yeah I guess so well he didn't you know stopping him strangle people poisoning people with apples all that so let's let's get so let us cut to the chase now Tom so in January 1939 news broke on the west coast that two German physicists Otto Hahn and Fritz Strassmann had demonstrated that you could split the nucleus of uranium, which is one of the heaviest elements in the periodic table, if you bombarded it with neutrons, with subatomic particles. The resulting fission will see a gigantic release of energy. And right away, people around the world see that this could produce a bomb the like of which humanity had
never seen. A bomb that may come to threaten the very survival of humanity itself. Very good, Tom. That's your Channel 5 documentary voiceover sorted. Just so everyone understands what's at stake. So that autumn, President Roosevelt set up what he called the Uranium Committee to research this. He said, we have to be on top of it. So he got his top boffins onto the case. Actually, took a year before the rad lab at berkeley began working on this and oppenheimer himself became involved i mean of course they are well known for being very left wing so you can understand why the government so to be fair it's roosevelt well right it's not as
never seen. A bomb that may come to threaten the very survival of humanity itself. Very good, Tom. That's your Channel 5 documentary voiceover sorted. Just so everyone understands what's at stake. So that autumn, President Roosevelt set up what he called the Uranium Committee to research this. He said, we have to be on top of it. So he got his top boffins onto the case. Actually, took a year before the rad lab at berkeley began working on this and oppenheimer himself became involved i mean of course they are well known for being very left wing so you can understand why the government so to be fair it's roosevelt right it's not as
left as they are but certainly by october 1941 so this is a few months before the united states enters the um second world war they have a few months before the United States enters the Second World War, they have a secret meeting at the General Electric headquarters in New York, upstate New York. Is Reagan there? No, Reagan is not. I knew. Oh, hello. What happens if I press this?
Oh, shit. I knew as soon as I said General Electric that you would think of Ronald Reagan. For those people who don't know, in our Reagan series, we talked about Reagan's work in the 1950s as a kind of front man for General Electric. So he might have been there. It would have been a bit later. He would have been there if it was 20 years later. At this point, he was dressing up as a soldier, wasn't he? Well, he was a soldier, wasn't he?
He was, and appearing with monkeys. They talk about how basically they will need loads of this particular isotope of uranium, which is called U-235, which is the only isotope, Tom, that can sustain a chain reaction. And they will need this for a nuclear bomb. And Oppenheimer is all over this stuff. And even at this point, they have a real sense that they are in a race against time with Nazi scientists. So I know you've been watching a lot of Indiana Jones films. And obviously, Nazi scientists and people about ilk play a large part in these things so there's an element of a sort of thriller about this now yeah they know
that the nazis it's the equivalent of the race of the ark of the covenant exactly exactly and dominic where is britain in this britain is off doing its own thing britain has a project called tube alloys um which will end up being kind of folded into the manhattan project but at this stage the american project is its own thing but it's are they ahead of britain and germany uh no they have a sense i was going to come to this but they have quite a strong sense of being behind their sense is that partly because of it was the hans strassman who made the great theoretical breakthrough and partly you know the germans have verner heisenberg who's the most famous young physicist on the planet and of course they think well the germ have probably been, because they've been in
the war for two years already, they have probably been throwing tons of resources at this. And don't the Germans sort of have heavy water at Telemark or something? I know nothing of heavy water, Tom. That's where my scientific knowledge runs out. I don't even know if it's relevant. Okay. There's something to do with Norway. Okay.
And there's heavy water there or something. I don't know. My brother would know about Okay. There's something to do with Norway. Okay. And there's heavy water there or something. I don't know. My brother would know about that. Let's draw a veil over that. Let's get back to Oppenheimer. So May 1942, he has made the director of the fast neutron research for a new secret committee, which is called S1. And he's absolutely passionate about doing this.
So he believes, as most of these scientists do, there are lots of Jewish scientists among them. And at this point, there is no sense whatsoever that this will be directed. Even though they're fighting Japan, this will be used against Japan. All their sense is this will be used against the Germans. In fact, Oppenheimer tells one of his colleagues,
Edward Teller, a man who will feature more heavily in this story, in the summer of 1942, explicitly says to him, only a nuclear bomb can dislodge Hitler from his conquered territories in Europe. And, I mean, is the intention that they will use it or that they will say, we will use it unless you unconditionally surrender? Or what's the military planning on that? I think at that point, they have no clear plan. Because they don't know how devastating it will be. No, because they don't know when, what the situation will be when they finally got there.
They don't know how long it will take. Of course, it's going to take them another three years. They don't have a sort of a finely worked out strategy for how to use this. Now, Oppenheimer is aware, even at this stage, that there is a big problem, and that is the communist problem. So he says to his friends that summer in 1942, I'm cutting all my contacts with people who were in the communist party. I know that the government will not want me unless I do this,
that I have this passed, basically. And in fact, in August 1942, the War Department said they were very unhappy about using Oppenheimer. They didn't really want to give him security clearance. They said, listen, he's been hobnobbing with these people who have security risks for years. It's not like a one-off. And who are Stalinists. And who are Stalinists. But he gets an absolutely crucial ally who is one of the big figures in the story of the Manhattan Project, who is a guy called colonel leslie r groves so colonel groves had graduated fourth in his class at west point he's in his late 40s he is an immensely dedicated ruthless organizer that's what he is he's an organizer one of his aides one of his closest aides said to, said of him, he was the biggest son of a bitch I ever worked
for. I hated his guts. But he then said he got things done. And that was, he was the person you brought in to get stuff done, to run projects and things. So Groves in the autumn of 1942, he takes over what was then called the Manhattan Engineer District, ends up being called the Department of Substitute Materials, but we know as the Manhattan Project. And why is it Manhattan? Because there was some office in Manhattan. Because I always wondered that, because Manhattan's a long way from Los Alamos.
It's a long way. But as you see, Los Alamos is not even on their radar at this point. Oh, okay. Because I always thought that they were working in Los Alamos. They do end up working in Los Alamos, but that's because of Oppenheimer. So they haven't even got there yet. So Groves and Oppenheimer have lunch and Oppenheimer, and they're so different, but what they have in common is this sort of single-minded obsessiveness about the security clearance issue. You are my man that I want to run a single laboratory, which will gather all these great brains and that we will dedicate it to this weapon. And I want one person to run it.
And that person is you. And why have they fixed on Oppenheimer? Because he's the best scientist or because they sense that he has the personal qualities? When you say they, it's really only he. It's only Groves. Lots of other people say. Was he spotted? Well, when you say they, it's really only he. It's only Groves. Lots of other people say- What's he spotted? Well, that's the fascinating thing, because lots of Groves' superiors and colleagues say,
why Oppenheimer? He's risky. And Groves just says, I see something in him. This, I think, is the obsessiveness, actually. Okay, so it's the obsessiveness rather than his evident pedigree as a scientist. The pedigree as a scientist is part of it. But what he's actually getting him to do is to run the thing, to manage it, to manage hundreds of other scientists, which is not something Oppenheimer has ever done.
And I wouldn't say that his track record necessarily suggests he'd be very good at it, with his whole strangling people and poisoned apples and things. I agree with you. But he has cleaned up his act since then. There's been very few strangling related incidents. So Oppenheimer is going to be the man. But, and this is, everyone should stop what you're doing and listen to this bit of the podcast.
Oppenheimer has a terrible conversation about this point a few weeks later, the autumn of 1942, or perhaps the early weeks of 1943. He has his old friend, Hawkins Chevalier, the autumn of 1942, or perhaps the early weeks of 1943, he has his old friend, Hawkins Chevalier, the French literature guy, round for dinner back in California. And at that dinner party, Chevalier says to him, I have a friend called George, who asked me to pass on a message to you. It seems very unfair that we are now talking to the British and sharing secrets with them. But our gallant allies in the East, who are doing so much of allied unity and actually winning the war against the Nazis and for you to pass on a few, you know, what you know. And Oppenheimer does one very good thing and one very foolish thing.
The very good thing is he says, no, I'm not interested. You know, this is not for me. There's no doubt about that. He didn't pass on secrets to the Soviets. But the thing that's very foolish is he doesn't report the conversation. He doesn't tell anybody about it. Is it, but is it just them? In the room. But the thing that's very foolish is he doesn't report the conversation. He doesn't tell anybody about it. But is it just them? In the room. Just the two of them? Yeah, I think their wives are around and they're in the kitchen or something
and it's just a quiet word. So very deniable. Very deniable. But, well, as we will see, even for his own self-protection, he absolutely should have mentioned it in his failure to do so. Though you might say laudable because he's protecting a friend,
this will really come back to bite him. But of course he doesn't know this at the time. At the time he is planning for what becomes Los Alamos. So in November 1942, he goes with a small group, including Groves, to New Mexico. They go to a place called Jemez Springs near Santa Fe, a canyon. And they say, Oppenheimer says, it's too small. We won't be able to build a little town down here. Why don't we go up to the end of the canyon and keep going? I used to ride around
here. There's a boys' school. They go up there and they go to the boys' school and Groves says, brilliant, this is the place. I mean, that's literally what he says. He says brilliant this is the place i mean that's literally what he says he says this is the place and two days later the u.s army buys the boys school that oppenheimer visited all those years ago and they just transform it they bring in loads of machines they bring in generators and cyclotrons and lab things and what's the cyclotron it's an important lab thing and um they uh at first they open in March and they have only 100 people. But by the time they're really running in mid-1945, they have 6,000 people and Oppenheimer is basically running the show. It's amazing. I mean, considering how unsuited to running 6,000 people,
everything that you've said about him seems to mark him. But he's good at it, Tom. I mean, as we know, they did it. I know. He's very good at it because of this sort of demented single-mindedness, I suppose. He drives them really hard. They believe that the Germans, at this point, they believe the Germans are two years ahead of them. But is he and the other boffins, are they actually in the army or are they just linked
to the army? Well, most of the people in Los alamos are not in the army so there are 4 000 people who are not in the army in 2000 who are um oppenheimer himself he has the specially commissioned uniform which he wears all the time to show you know to i suppose to show that he's an authority figure that he's not just a scientist um he was commissioned as a lieutenant colonel even though he failed the medical so he was medically completely you know partly because he's just been eating artichokes and not just a scientist. He was commissioned as a lieutenant colonel even though he failed the medical. So he was medically completely, partly because he'd just
been eating artichokes and chocolate for 30 years. And he can't move in a chemistry lab without knocking over a burner. I mean,
he'd be good in the cavalry, Tom, with all his riding. Yeah, that's true. And he'd be good as a sort of,
as an assassin with his strangling, his gretting. And his apples. Right. But not as a conventional um as a conventional infantryman or something now so he's running them you know they're doing all this stuff to kind of prepare for the bomb but all through this there are doubts about him so for one thing
he started seeing jean tatlock again okay she's still a communist. Florence Butte, she's still a communist. Now, whether they're having an affair or whether they're just seeing each other's friends, who knows? We don't know, but he's certainly seeing her. Secondly, the FBI and army intelligence, both are very concerned about him. So all through this period, they are tapping his phone, they read his letters, they wiretap his office. Even his chauffeur, his driver, is an agent for army counterintelligence. They are so worried. And they actually say to him, whenever you leave Los Alamos, if you drive into Albuquerque or Santa Fe or somewhere, we will be tailing you. We will be watching you. So from this point onwards, he's actually always under
scrutiny. I didn't realize this. I thought that the communist issue, as it were, came out of nowhere in the 1950s. I mean, it's less toxic for him at this point because, as you said, the Soviets are still American allies. That's right. That's right. So he can sort of, it's not so toxic. That said, in the late summer of 1943, he has his second great disastrous conversation. And this is, he hears that they are worried about communist influence at Berkeley, the radiation laboratory.
And it's at this point that he reports, so very late, months late, that he decides he will report the conversation with Chevalier about possibly being an agent for the Soviets. And he's interviewed by a man with a slightly peculiar name of Boris Pash, who's an ex kind of white Russian or something, who works for army intelligence. And he gives a very, very poor performance. He's very vague about the conversation. And he's also inaccurate. He says, I don't think it's just me they approached. He was approaching three other scientists as well, which is a kind of detail that he's made up that's not true. And it's not clear whether he's made that up so that it's not just him and that he doesn't look so bad, or he's made it up because he wants it to look bigger than it is. He himself said, I don't know why I said that. It just wasn't really true. But the fact is he's
given this very rambling, shambolic performance. And whenever the FBI, when they later interrogate him, he's always a bit vague and evasive. And I think because he feels guilty, you know, because as we all would, he feels under pressure and a bit shifty and anxious. So he's a very bad. And that, unfortunately, does not put it to bed. It means that among the FBI and among the U.S. Army intelligence, there are people who think he's hiding something. You know, there's something fishy about Oppenheimer, something not quite right. And actually, even at this point, Groves is still having to kind of stick up for him and say, no, he's my man. We'll get him to do it. One other thing before we move on to the very end of the story, this part of the story anyway. At the end of 1943, a chap called Niels Bohr arrives at Los Alamos, a great Danish physicist.
Now, he had gone on this amazing journey. He had been smuggled out of Denmark into Sweden. And then in Sweden, he was kind of bundled into the kind of bomb bit of an unmarked British bomber and then flown to England. They had an oxygen mask for him to wear because he could he would probably pass out possibly die on the flight if he didn't have oxygen but he misheard the instructions and didn't put it on so he did pass out but he didn't die which is just as well uh he joins the british nuclear project which was called tube alloys and the british agree that they will send boar as they end up sending lots of their scientists to los alamos to collaborate on the Manhattan project. And it's when Bohr gets to Los Alamos that he says, I know for a fact, because I had
a conversation with him, that Werner Heisenberg in Germany is working on a Nazi bomb. So the pressure is really on. But Bohr also does something else. He says to Oppenheimer, once we've done this, we should share this with the world. It shouldn't just be an American or British thing. We should share it with everybody because in this new age, we have to be completely open and there can't be any secrecy. We have to build a new, more idealistic, more international world. Sharing the benefits of atomic energy is a massive part of this. Now, Bohr went around saying this in the final years of the war. He said it to Churchill, and Churchill said afterwards to his men, you know, that bloke should be locked up. Like, this is a very bad idea. But Oppenheimer, because of his kind of ethical culture stuff and his kind of social gospel, Judaism, and all this business.
He's into that. He loves it. He thinks this is great. This is a great step towards a world government and all this great fun. So this again is going to be a sort of little ticking time bomb in Oppenheimer's career. So let's fast forward since we're reaching the end of this episode. We're into 1945. Roosevelt died in the middle of April.
Hitler killed himself on the 30th of April. It's clear at this point the bomb is not going to be used against Nazi Germany. They're not going to need to. The Nazis have lost the race, so the Nazis never did build a nuclear bomb. And as when Germany crashed out of the war in May 1945, obviously the next target is Japan. And at this point, to put the decision that will be made in the next episode into context, at this point, the American bombing raids on Japan have reached such a peak that in the most famous one on the 9th of March 1945, the firebombing of Tokyo, they destroyed 16 square miles of the Japanese capital and killed 100,000 people. But also, Dominic, just to put that into context, they are also fighting an incredibly brutal war in the Pacific. And the projections of military strategists is that millions of people on both sides will die if there is a land invasion of Japan. That's right. That's absolutely right. I mean, there are ferocious arguments about the decision to, I mean, among historians, I mean, about the decision to drop the first atom bomb on Hiroshima
and then the second on Nagasaki. And maybe we'll come to this a little bit in the second episode. I think there was never any doubt the Truman administration were going to do it. And Oppenheimer, at this point, he seems to have had a few private doubts, but by and large, he's happy to go along with it. I mean, the context is that Germany's been defeated, and certainly the British are exhausted, and America is desperate not to lose millions of people. And so presumably this is weighing on what's happening at Los Alamos. They're thinking this could be a cutting of the Gordian Knot. It's not just that.
He thinks it's the weapon to end all wars. Oppenheimer does. Yes. But presumably the US military and Truman don't think that. No, the US military and Truman are thinking purely, I think they've got two things on their minds. One is winning the war against Japan, and the other is the Soviet Union's Darnham.
And this is a massive historiographical this is one of the hottest most hotly contested debates in all american historiographies so we don't really have time of course the key thing though tom is they have to make sure it works so that summer they choose the place the place is called i mean you could hardly you couldn't make this up. It's called the Jornada del Muerto, the Journey of Death. The place is the sort of... That's literally its name. Yeah. That's the Spanish name. Nominative determinism. Nominative determinism, indeed. It's about 120 miles southeast of Albuquerque,
New Mexico. It's Oppenheimer who says we'll call it Trinity. I don't know why he, no one knows why he chose that title. He just said... Apparently from a John Dunn poem. Yeah. There were some people who say because he loved the poet John Donne. Which he'd been introduced to by Florence Pugh. Is that right?
Apparently, yeah. I mean, thank God he didn't name himself to George Eliot. Yeah. Reawakening memories of that disastrous spell at summer camp. And so that quote that you read at the beginning of the episode, that's what happens at 5.30 a.m. on the morning of the 16th of July, 1945. And this is an extraordinary moment in world history. It is the beginning of the atomic age. It's the moment at which, if you're going to use that Promethean device, it's the moment at which humankind gets
its hands on fire. Well, I mean, it's more than just human history. I mean, the whole history of the planet. Yeah. And so as you said afterwards, many years later, Oppenheimer said that he thought about that line from the Bhagavad Gita, now I am become death, the destroyer of worlds. But actually, at the time, he said something quite different. So the New York Times, there's a guy from the New York Times who has been chosen. He's basically embedded. He's been chosen by Groves to report the event. And Oppenheimer says to him that the blast was terrifying, but not entirely under-pressing. And then he pauses and he says, lots of boys who are not yet grown up will owe their lives to this, which is a counterintuitive note on which to which to end
on that we will take a break and finish today's episode and we will be back with the second half of this story so the way the atom bomb is used in japan oppenheimer's views on that all the kind of historiographical complexities around it and then the story of Oppenheimer's downfall. And ultimately, he gets kind of rehabilitated, doesn't he? So we will see you for part two very soon, unless, of course, you are a member of the Restless History Club, in which case we can see you immediately, because you can go and listen to it right now. So we will either see you, well, you know, in a few minutes or in a few days.
Either way, bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不管怎样，再见，再见，谢谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要收听独家播客、提前畅听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。评论、一点娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想无广告收听、获取独家播客并优先购买现场门票，请访问 theredefentertainment.com，网址是：本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。